hello everybody hope that you're good
I'm filming this in October 31st
Halloween I'm sure that somebody asked
Market maker trick or treat and he said
trick because look at all those red
candles there in the one hour time frame
we're going to talk that in a moment
sorry for the bad joke for now we're
want to go first to the Daily time frame
because I would like to start the video
where I finished the last one and no
more jokes during this video sorry we're
going to stick to technical analysis uh
um what we were talking in the last
video was about this structure here as a
channel I already explain my motives in
the last video why I didn't treat this
as a range but yes as a channel and so
far is behaving like a channel I'm not
going to lie okay so it's looking good
and also explained how I thought that
most Traders didn't probably take
advantage of this move because when they
saw these two red daily candles here at
65k and 60k they were thinking okay
we're going to drop to the bottom of the
channel we're going to go to 50
152k and that is not how a how a channel
usually works usually right before the
breakout because we all can agree that
in this structure there is going to be a
breakout to the upside but right before
it you go to the top of the channel and
then you drop to the 50% level to the
mid level of this channel which is right
here I already saw it in the last video
and from there if you see a reaction
it's very likely that you see something
like this okay a breakout and then as I
talked in the last video we wna I said
that we were probably going to see 69 4K
we to we went to
69.5k is and from there we had the
retest okay to the to the top of the
channel of support we got two chances
there and I call this in advance so it's
not hand sight and from there
continuation for a new L up
okay now something that I also mentioned
in the last video was that if you notice
here you have your your high and if I
mark this level here that is going to be
a resistance okay so in yellow you have
the high in order to have resistance if
I mark this levels here you can see one
2 three four times and we were talking
about the idea how in between this High
which is the yellow line and this
resistant Line Orange there was a lot of
liquidity in between and price needed to
get there now you can see how exactly
this week we fill that space and now
price is getting R from there okay cuz
we already grab all the all of that
liquidity there so um I'm glad that I
played out um because I was hoping and I
was putting my money there so I'm glad
that these setups are playing out
now if you into the 4-Hour time frame
there is a few things here of concern
look at this what do you see let me put
indicator it's going to make it easier
for you you have two things okay the
first thing is this 4our 50 ma which is
at
69,7 right now which could be a
potential support and the other thing is
this liquidity pool that is new and is
getting marked now um this liquidity
pool is being formed because these fast
drops in the 1 hour time frame okay
these fast drops are creating an
imbalance there and price should retrace
that imbalance especially because it
happen so Qui so quickly and so
aggressively forming very large scandles
all right so in conclusion what I'm
paying attention here is uh what I would
like to see in fact is a drop towards
this level here okay towards the 4our 50
ma now if in this area we can see some
kind of reaction that will be telling me
okay that would be telling me that price
could attempt to retrace this liquidity
pool at 72k that is what I'm paying
attention to now of course it's a very
volatile week and and next week to next
week we have the elections in the USA
that's really big that's going to be
quite annoying to trade because it's
going to be quite difficult to to guess
what is going to happen so this Bitcoin
Sund update that I'm going to do next
Sunday is going to be a really difficult
one because um what can I expect I mean
how can the elections influence the
price of Bitcoin depending on who wins
the elections is Bitcoin going to do one
thing or the other it's difficult to
know all these things so uh what I would
say is that between well I I've said
this in Sunday H trade light okay trade
light until after the elections simply
because also this week we've had Google
earning reports we got Microsoft earning
reports meta earning reports all of
those ones having positive ones but
today is Thursday and today right after
the market closes right after New York
closes we have apple and Amazon earnings
reports which are really important and
it's going to determine what Bitcoin is
going to do next because Bitcoin is
going to be trading Bitcoin trades 24/7
nonstop so the stocks and the S&P is
going to be closed but Bitcoin is going
to react to those news and also tomorrow
we go H the employment data so that's
also going to be
big So based on that information what I
would say and I've been saying this for
for the last few days is to trade light
until after the elections from there
we're want to see things a bit more
clear and we can trade with a more more
size okay that's what I would say now if
we go to High block capital I want to I
want to I want to talk you about
something because but let me first take
you here to the 1 hour time
frame um another thing that I took this
week and I mention it on telegram was to
open some short positions from 72 .2k
all the way to 73k all right that was
the top and the only reason for that was
mainly because we were really
overextended from the 1 hour 50 m which
is this purple line here look at that I
mean if you take it from
here that's a 10% move 9 50% move okay
without a single
retrace that is not sustainable that
needs to retrace and the only way why I
took the my short in this
area in this area here and not in this
area here was because of experience
and I'm sure many Traders have to open
well the open a short here then have to
add some margin in this area here and
now they are roughly in profits okay but
uh what I want to say with this is that
my short is fully closed now I closed H
most of my position here and then today
also I close the rest 40% of my position
so I'm right now with without a position
open and flat and I'm waiting for a new
trade and the next trade that I'm going
to take is possibly going to be a long
trade looking for this liquidity pool to
get retrace okay now from there the
question is if I'm looking to enter
along what can I enter from so let's go
to hlo Capital let's see if we see uh
some new information when h capital
liquidation levels first the heat map
that's the rule do you guys know it and
I'm using the max liquidity settings so
take these amounts with a pinch of salt
I always say the same um I'm using this
setting because that's what I'm used to
I know how to treat this Delta very well
with these amounts because I've been
using this for a few years so I'm
sticking to this um methodology now you
can see that right at the top of this
uptrend we had in the Delta $21 billion
worth of long liquidations in that
moment okay that is qu L that's high
risk of a retrace usually between 30 35
billions that that's to me imminent risk
of a retrace and between 20 and 30 is a
high risk of uh any moment it can happen
it's building quite a lot so it needs to
be wiped and you can see also here
during this consolidation how all those
liquidations got reduced to $15 billion
yeah so so that is pretty much because
what you see consolidation of the highs
there are many long positions that going
to be closing or they're going to be
taking some profits of the table or
they're risking and that's why the the
long liquidations are getting reduced in
that time but today and to me this is
key he went all the way down to six look
at that it went all the way down to six
that's more than half okay got Reduce by
more than half pretty much
pretty much at
66% and I think that's quite healthy um
it sounds about um I feel sorry for all
those traders that lost money here of
course nobody nobody like that and we
follow in there but in terms of Market
structure and liquidity is quite healthy
to reset Delta at zero okay and we're
pretty much at zero right now to me five
is very close to zero in in these terms
now from here very a few spikes of
liquidity below us which are this one
here
69,000 and this one here which is qu
lower and I'm not going to be paying any
attention to it right now which is 67 to
5K that one to me right now is too far
and as a day trader is not a level where
I'm opening uh a trade in the in in the
short term perhaps if we start to see
price going there then yes I can
consider it that idea but right now
we're at 70k so that level to me seems a
far away as a day trader um not as a
swing trade up as a day trader yes so
the level that I'm keeping an eye on
here is
69,000 what it was here
69,000 that is the first piece of
information that we can get there also I
must say that there was a lot of Longs
opening here because there were a lot of
new Traders or unexperienced traders
that they were trying to open Longs
because they were hoping for a new a new
are the highest a new high in Bitcoin
and the market maker likes to play with
those hopes so yes sometimes you can see
this count of price action that is
basically to to wreck those Traders open
and Longs in order
to for them to make money in simple
terms now if you go to the equation hit
map guys there is not much information
here in the 7 Days time frame especially
there is nothing that is
available no much information or no much
liquidity around 74k and to the downside
65,000 again it's too far away too far
away for for me guys and in the monthly
time
frame we can see a bit more
here and is that we go liquidity again
is around
65k but also above the previous High
okay and that will be our alltime highs
and that's around
74,000
74,400 so yes it's possible that we see
a new a new high quite soon I'm not
dismissing the idea but what I was
dismissing was the idea of pumping all
the way here without a single retrace
that's why I took a short here at the
high because I was expecting first
retrace now that retrace is now fully
closed
and my idea is to open a new long so
let's go back to the
Chart so with that new information we
can Mark another level in the chart
which is
69,000
and that was some liquidations there and
we have now two areas I would even say
that between the 50a in the 4 hours time
frame and those liquidations there at
69,000 that area there is a potential
bounce area boom I would only have more
confidence on on on that bounce if we
see the drop here happening very fast
very soon for that I'll tell you what I
think you guys remember that if you go
into the one hour time
frame I was opening shorts here okay
simply because the 50 ma was very ere
extended right you remember so in the 15
minutes time frame is happening pretty
much the same look at that we're really
ere extended from the 50 EMA in the 15
minutes time frame and and let me change
this now let me Mark the 4H hour
50a if we actually continue dropping
very soon ideally I would say that it
would have to happen by today's New York
session closing maybe I don't know
Google or Amazon reports are negative
and that can set up this move between
these two areas if that is the case and
that happens quite quickly without any
strong bounce here I don't want to say
that okay I don't want to say that I
want to drop from here if we see that
then the 15 minutes the 15 minute 50 Ma
so it's quite confusing to say is going
to be even more overextended and price
at this point here it's going to need to
catch up with it okay I don't know what
this will be maybe it's around
I would say it's probably going to be
around this point here okay so yes maybe
you have here an inverse Head and
Shoulders call it as you want but yes if
we see this move here this drop then
that is what I'm opening Longs with a
lot of confidence that price is going to
pump straight into the 15 minute 50 ma
all right now from there we could even
see higher move into this liquidity pool
here okay now let me change again
chart Market the liquidity
pull okay
okay on and
here so you can
see that liquidity pull there all right
so what I'm looking for is that give me
this drop happening very fast the 15
minute 15a is going to be more ere
extended and from there you can see the
bounce here if we can get above this
area then boom we are going to retrace
this liquidity pull all right otherwise
of course and as always if we lose the
4H hour 50 ma if we lose this level here
and then we don't need a bounce from
here so if we continue dropping here
then yes we can look at those levels
like
67,000 we can even look for a new uh
retrace of this trend line here also you
can notice how the daily 50ma is also
pretty much matching there so yes I
would even say that if we fail to to
hold a
69,000 then it's very likely that we go
the way again to
65 66k all right so that's pretty much
everything guys I give you that quick
idea for a potential long trade uh do
you guys know it now let's see if that
is about to happen next if it does then
I'll be very happy to to have made money
of that trate and and of course to also
share it with you in life so that's
pretty much everything guys thank you
very much and I'll see you soon